Guten Morgen guten Morgen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik number 251 vom heute 25 April.
Ein Tag vorm Vorverkauf ein Tag und ein Monat vor der LMP2 56.
Stell mir gleich mehr leben jetzt und alle Kollektiv gekreuzigt werden in Deutschland.
Ja fürchterlich wie Vivianne man mit was für Probleme so eine Gesellschaft sich über Jahrzehnte rum schleppt und keiner weiß es ne und dann werde ich einfach gelöst und alles befreit so können wir auf einmal wieder christliche Werte in jeder Behörde.
An die Wand tackern und alle Probleme sind gelöst wir vorher nicht hatten.
Genau auf Kredit sie CSU die wie ich dann lernte er das Grundgesetz ja nicht akzeptiert hat also Aktie das ist die falsche Formulierung das gibt gleich wieder Ärger den Kommentaren sie hat dagegen gestimmt damals.
Immerhin ich meine weiß man was man hat die sind ihren Prinzipien treu geblieben das kann man anderen Parteien nicht unbedingt nachsagen.
Genau wir warten immer Verfassungsfeinde was wollt ihr.
Ja ja ja das ist schon so ein bisschen absurd irgendwie mein hätte das nicht mit der Trennung von Religion und Staat noch mal ein bisschen klarer reinschreiben können irgendwo.
Trennung von Hirn und Geist wer bei den mal irgendetwas mit den los.
Begriffe Gehirn und Geist ist da schon durch implementiert naja also muss man so glaube ich nicht groß mit also ich hänge jetzt hier nicht noch ein Kreuz ins Studio.
Nee ist kein Star kallax.
Nee hast du fein Server dich drauf.
Schick mir hier vielleicht noch mal einen goldenen Apfel hin so schön wie der Titel CBD ist ja ganz toll.
Zur Verteidigung unserer freiheitlichen Werte der Disco Tischen Werte.
This condition Grundordnung Verteidigung der discussion Grundordnung.
Mit F schreibst du das ja.
Lasse das wir müssen hier Werbung machen noch.
Genau eine kurze Leitung Höhe.
Versenden an Tim ich habe dir gesagt wie das geht.
Ja es wurde die ganze Nacht durchgearbeitet haben müssen wir jetzt hier.
Ja wer tatsächlich die ganze Zeit.
Noch rechtzeitig in die Mittagspause schaffen.
Genaue p256 steht vor der Tür es wird passieren.
Altbekanntes Konzept-e neben Kino in life zeichnen mehrere Gäste und wir machen eine Gala in besonderem Ambiente und wir machen ein Vorverkauf.
Der startet.
Am 26.04 ich weiß auch die Uhrzeit aber der Tim traut sich nicht dir zu sagen weil er sonst weil er Angst hat dass er vielleicht eine Minute zu spät den Shop online schaltet oder Donner mal die Preise ändern will.
Laufe des Tages.
Im Laufe des Tages des 26.04.
Ein Tages genau.
Und ihr findet den Link unter https Doppelpunkt Slash Slash.
Logbuch Netzpolitik. De Schrägstrich 256 jetzt sucht er zweimal raten ob die Zahl oder ausgeschrieben ich würde an Eurer Stelle als erstes die Zahl probieren 256.
Genau ist auch einfacher zu tippen,
ja wir haben da jetzt viel drüber gefesselt wie man in das nun alles strukturiert und macht und tut und das ist irgendwie alles nicht so einfach weil man einerseits die Realitäten der Örtlichkeit,
also in dem Fall jetzt Babylon berücksichtigen muss uns dann natürlich auch allen recht machen will.
Ja wird.
Gibt im größeren Zuschauerraum dass es so der Großteil der der Sitzplätze gibt der gemütliche Kinosessel in diesem Etablissement.
Und zusätzlich gibt's noch spezielle Bereiche.
Promo Bereich Höxter.
Spezielle Bereiche im Parkett also unten.
Hinter den Hauptstuhl Rhein auch noch so Separees wenn wir dann als Ticket sehen die Kosten jetzt auch nichts anderes als die anderen Ticket auch aber solltet ihr aus irgendwelchen Gründen gerne in einer Vierergruppe zusammen sein.
Und mit so einer Eingangstür und so.
Mein Blick dann quasi auf dieselbe Bühne so durch Sonne fensterloses also das lose Fenster.
Ja aber man ist daher vielleicht ein bisschen kompakter Ball beisammen und hatte seine gemütlichen Stühle.
Man ist unter sich mein ist vor ein Blick geschützt zumindest von hinten wird man nicht mehr gesehen man kann als seine eigene Tür das ist ja auch manchmal nicht schlecht wenn man eine schwache Blase hat.
Aber da geht auch das Rauchverbot hätte jetzt hier auf schlimme Riesenkrabben.
Das Rauchverbot ja das Rauchverbot gilt dort auch.
Ist universell aber das sind diese Separees aber für Leute der besonderen Geschmacksrichtung.
Weil ich jetzt eine Separees eignen sich für wirklich Vierergruppen oder also das Mandat in der Gruppe zusammen sitzen möchte und der Mann daneben sein eigenen Zugang eigenen Raum.
The beatnuts aber mit Anwalt ist kann man gibt halt einfach könnt den Blick dann auch selber überprüfen werden auch Fotos zu den einzelnen Ticketkategorien mit dabei.
Stimmt das ist ja wichtig wärme Illustration Feder einzeln Ticketkategorie die wo ihr anschauen könnt wie es da wirklich aussieht und wo sich euer Platz dann dort befinden wird.
Laut müssen etwa genauso in dem jeweiligen Sitzbereich nach dir dann frei Wahl aber wir unterscheiden halt.
Die normalen Tickets die ist auch in einer ermäßigten Variante gibt und eben dann diese Sonderbereiche ein weiterer Sonderbereich.
Sind Logen wie schon bei Logbuch Netzpolitik 200 gibt es oben auf dem Balkon spezielle Logen Bereiche.
Ja da gibt's 24 und 28 Logen.
Genau das ist so für unsere.
Wölfe einfach nicht so aufs Geld achten muss gleich mal weiter.
Tim ist auch mal was wert ist den besonderen Blick zu genießen.
Wenn man sich sagt Pfarrer.
Und wenn schon wenn schon mal Tim und Linus sehen dann auch in die Vollen gehen ja.
Warum nicht mal eine Longe.
Einmal richtig aufdrehen den Schalter auf die Elf legen und gib ihm.
Der sitzt ja also oben am Balkon.
Erhöht in dieser einzeldose und könnte an über alle anderen Zuschauer hinweg zu schauen bin hinweg auf das Geschehen blicken neben in der Mitte,
wird an der nach aktueller Planung zwischen den Logen der live Zeichner Roland sitzen und eventuell auch eine Wok Kamera.
Das aber das ist im Moment noch Planung das heißt er wird dir denn so kg an den an den Stellen wo man das komplette Geschehen im Überblick habt ihr eure eigene Loge mit.
Lass uns da noch was einfallen dass er da euch auch dann ganz wohlfühlen werdet in die.
Aber ist jetzt nicht so eine Waldorf und Statler Situation wo er dann kichernd von der Seite euch über die Vortragenden lustig machen könnt das könnt ihr natürlich schon aber es hat nicht jeder.
Ja ja nee nee ihr kriegt kein echtes Mikrofon.
Wer meine Idee aber ich glaube das bitte nicht bezahlen.
Loge denke ich mal so für für die business events mein Held ja gerne mal mein Lied ja gerne mal vielleicht so ein paar.
Geschäftspartner.
Reiche Magnaten.
Zum gepflegten Rand ins Papier schneiden.
Okay genug gequatscht.
Loge wie Loge wie gehabt dann gibt's noch einen weiteren Bereich und das ist das heißt wenn man.
Das Luxus Ticket Hüftleiden bannis.
Nee das ist du lachst du kennst den Begriff nicht das ist weil du nicht zum Stones gehst hin ich gehe jetzt on stones.
Du gehst von stones.
Selbstverständlich ist von stones.
Ja super toller Held.
Das kann ich Erzähler wenig privates Alters kann ich erzählen als ich Abitur gemacht habe jetzt könnte Google weil ich Abitur gemacht da war an dem Tag.
Spielten die Rolling Stones und meine Mutter sagte Linus.
Zur Feier des Tages gehen wir zu den Stones wer weiß wie lange die Stadt nachmachen.
Das ist ein paar Jahre her das ist mehr als 10 Jahre her dass ich Abitur gemacht habe und die Stones kommen wieder.
Und wir gehen wieder hin natürlich weil wer weiß wie lange die das noch machen.
Aber das ist also Song wenn du also bist du aushalten da gibt's natürlich dann oder bei bei vielen Konzerten da gibt's ja noch mal den front of stage Bereich front of stage ist quasi vorne der der vordere Bereich.
An der Bühne in dem Fall natürlich Stehplätze.
Ich weiß da wo die Unterhosen geschmissen werden.
Kinder Unterhosen Weitwurf für die die ihre Unterhose.
Oder wollen.
Bei uns ist der front of stage das mit Sitzplätzen Unterhosen Wurf Verbot und.
Finde ich Tracks aber die Veranstaltung unnötig ein.
Okay also von Sitzplätze damit mein wie die ersten beiden rein die sind im Babylon so ein bisschen abgesetzt also sind wirklich noch mal sehr viel näher dran und wir wollen einfach im Prinzip auch so eine Klopperei um diese ersten Reihen vielleicht so ein bisschen.
Einmal bitte den Druck rausnehmen das heißt wir haben einen front of stage Bereich da geht's noch mal für einen kleinen Aufpreis.
Tickets also quasi garantiert in der ersten oder zweiten Reihe sitzen könnt.
Holz aus ansonsten gilt first come first serve.
Genau im innerhalb des front of stage Preis gilt das auch aber ihr wisst dann wenigstens ihr wollt jetzt keine Eile mehr zu haben ihr könnt ihr sitzroller Station und dann haben wir noch eine letzte Ticket Variante das ist wie es sich gehört die Rolli Variante.
Standard also Zeit normalen Ticketpreis oder den ermäßigte Ticketpreis und eine Begleitperson hat kostenlosen Eintritt.
Wie sich das gehört.
Wir machen wir haben dieses Ticket im Prinzip nur damit wir uns räumlich darauf einrichten könnt können und das vorbereiten können dass wir eben für euch dann auch entsprechende,
Plätze reservieren wo ihr zusammen mit eurer Begleitperson oder euren Begleitpersonen sitzen könnt das wär natürlich dann ganz nett falls jetzt mit mehr als einer Begleitperson kommt die sagt eine könnt ihr kostenlos mitbringen.
Dass wir uns dann einfach nur kurze Mail schreibt damit wir für euch Sorgen können dass ihr da angenehm akkumuliert werde bei uns.
Ja
Hör mal mehr das war heute ein Tag Debatte und Planung und mehr Tickets neuer Name gar nicht.
Die einfachen Lösungen sind die schwierigsten.
Ja den einer kann ich heute wirklich gehabt,
wirklich.
Ja da das war eigentlich das worüber wir am längsten diskutiert haben es ist folgendermaßen gewesen Hermes angeschaut wie war das bei der LMP2 100 und was haben wir da für einen durchschnittlichen Ticketpreis gehabt.
Der durchschnittliche Ticketpreis bei der LMP2 100 den wir erreicht haben war 25 €.
98 oder nee 25 € 21.
Das war der der durchschnittlich gezahlte Ticketpreis wir hatten neue Ticketpreise ab 23 € Standard Ticket 42 € Supporter Ticket.
Und haben durchschnittlich ein Ticket Preis von 25 €.
Noch was erzählt und dann haben wir uns heute die Kalkulation und den Ertrag so von der LMP2 111 von der mp200 angeschaut und haben uns überlegt so das war sehr schön das hat viel Spaß gemacht aber.
Wenn man die ganze Arbeit.
Wir haben auch Glück gehabt dass uns nicht in die Miesen gehen.
Genau wer im Glück gehabt dass das so aufgegangen ist wir haben da ein moderates Plus gemacht aber es war so an den Puck dass wir festgestellt haben so viele Leute wie wir da,
mit.
Beschäftigt haben soviel Zeit wie wir selber reingesteckt haben so viel Aufwand wie wir damit hatten dass das wirklich jetzt nicht so war als wäre das für uns besonders.
Was Linus sage wir müssen die Preise bisschen erhöhen,
und werden den Normalpreis auf 35 € pro Ticket setzen gibt noch ermäßigte Tickets in kleineres Kontingent von 25 € und die Spezialbereiche sind dann etwas teurer.
Und ich hoffe dass das Unverständnis stößt das ist einfach erforderlich ist offen auch dass wir das nicht das.
Nur das zweite Mal gemacht haben das auch häufiger da in die Spur gehen können und arbeiten jetzt auch da dran dass wir da ein bisschen mehr Routine in den ganzen Sport reinbekommen.
Um das einfach schneller abwickeln zu können kurzfristiger zugplan.
Das ist der eine Punkt und der philipp Reis noch mal sehen das halt auch als Navi geben uns noch mal besonders viel Mühe für euch und würden uns halt freuen wenn ihr euch da brauch.
Da die Gelegenheit nutzt uns ein bisschen finanziell zu unterstützen und uns entgegenzukommen weil.
Wir gerne Geld verdienen wollen mit diesem Event.
T-Shirts T-Shirts ich esse T-Shirt ja inzwischen mein Hobby seitdem ich ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit weiß nicht bei drei Jahren beim Kongress die T-Shirt Sachen.
Mache ja habe ich ja so ein bisschen Spaß dran.
Und kleide mich ja inzwischen nur noch irgendwie.
Wir werden ein Event Shirt machen das LMP 256 T-Shirt wird nur dort geben mit dem Design von dem Event was wir selbstverständlich nur für dieses Event anfertigen lassen.
Und das T-Shirt könnt ihr direkt mit vorbestellen T-Shirt kostet euch 30 €.
Damit das sind auch da ist natürlich eine Marge drin.
Die sich für uns niederlässt wir können aber auch oder erkennt ja vor allem auf den Anspruch von Tim,
sew shut Verkauf angeht weshalb wir z.b. keinen Spreadshirt Shop haben und nicht irgendwelchen Digitaldruck machen wir haben uns entschieden für ähnlich wie beim Kongress ziemlich genau wie beim Kongress.
Fair Wear Shirts also aus fairer Produktion nicht von irgendwelchen Kinderhänden in hast du nicht gesehen genäht,
Ökotex 100 zertifiziert Stoff und die ganze Produktion machen welche in Berlin bei Mittelständler.
Zu wie ich hoffe ordentlichen Bedingungen ordentlichen Preisen das heißt ihr kriegt da einen ordentlich plastisol siebdruck das T-Shirt nicht irgendwelche.
Verfasse ich geplottete Aufkleber oder fünf Mal waschen Digitaldrucke sondern bewerte Kongress Qualität.
Wie ihr das hoffentlich von uns auch nicht anders erwarten würde.
Ein T-Shirt wie ein Metaebene Podcast.
Bei diesem Wetter in der Backe und ich weiß z.b. ich kriege immer große tatsächlich relativ oft Feedback zu diesem fairwear und Ökotec Öko-Tex-Standard isierung ne,
bei der achten nicht viele drauf.
Aber die drauf achten wissen das wirklich auch zu schätzen und ich persönlich habe nie wirklich in Erwägung gezogen was anderes zu kaufen.
Also das ist irgendwie was ich natürlich im Preis bemerkbar wenn man auf diese Qualität und auf diese fairen Bedingungen achtet aber ja was anderes käme mir jetzt nicht in Sinn.
Ich werde die Gelegenheit haben diese T-Shirts gleich bei der Bestellung des Tickets mitzubestellen und bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte wenn ihr überhaupt nur erweckt das Shirt zu kaufen dann mach das bitte auch sind wir werden nur.
Unwesentlich mehr produzieren als da bestellt werden also etwas mehr muss man machen aber.
Für den Fall dass ihre.
Fast car wash Größe blablabla und doch mal wieder irgendeine Verpeiltheit und dann werdet ihr auch die Gelegenheit haben das vor Ort zu kaufen.
Aber und das Futter besonders wichtig um so gut einschätzen zu können welche Größen sind eigentlich gefragt ja wenn also für Girls und Boys die passenden Schnitte anbieten und ja,
so alle Größen bis 2XL oder so und 33 Excel.
Sollen wir eine andere Größe haben wollen bestellter zwei Gesellen schreibt uns noch eine Mail an sorgen für eine schöne also das ist nicht das Problem wir können unter Umständen.
Ja oder oder sagt es das.
Ovale Normgröße.
Oder sagt uns das vorher auf Twitter dann können wir das Anpassen also das ist flexibel da wir jetzt noch den Vorlauf haben,
bis Anfang Mai also ist jetzt eh bald aber wir müssen auch mal so zehn Tage Zeit wenn ja also da sozusagen Shirts bestellen wollt.
Heißt dass ihr die natürlich dann da auch abholt.
Die sind voll bezahlt ihr müsst ihr da abholen.
Ich produziere dann exakt die Shirts in den Größen die bestellt sind plus ein bisschen Verschnitt und dann könnt ihr sehr gemütlich kriegt ihr für das für das T-Shirt auch so.
Ticket.
Mit dem QR-Code und das könnt ihr dann gemütlich am Shirt Stand abholen vor der Veranstaltung nach der Veranstaltung wie es euch beliebt bitte bitte holt es ab wir bieten kein Versand an,
und es wird halt einfach nur also es einfach,
schwierig wenn jetzt dein Shirt bestellt und euch nicht darüber Gedanken macht das wird auch abgeholt werden muss so Abholung da vor Ort.
Bitte zur Not auch von falls ihr dann doch nicht kommen könnte das ganze auch jemand anders fahre ich ab heute Filme alles schon eine Lösung aber bitte bitte bitte nutzt die Gelegenheit up-front hier das zu erblicken.
Sonst gibt's cutcat not good for you.
Sonst gibt's glaube ich erstmal nicht soviel zu sagen wir werden euch in den nächsten Wochen natürlich weiter Anfüttern und ja hoffen dass ihr jetzt alle kommt.
Jazzgesang Wochenende noch andere Events in Berlin die im Anschluss stattfinden.
Gib immer Events.
Medienanschluss stattfinden kann also quasi das so mitnehmen.
Was besonderes.
Ich hatte tatsächlich was im Auge wenn ich jetzt hier die Sachen habe ich danach noch feiern gehen.
Ich habe mich habe schon was im Auge.
Ja also ihr wisst ja Berlin ist ja nicht arm an Optionen was feiern geht feiern angeht.
Oh mann halt keinen.
Ja wäre auch nicht schlecht.
Fitbag gab.
Reaktion auf dieses und jenes es gab zwei längliche feedbaxx ich weiß nicht was hier ist nicht komplett vorlesen aber da geht doch der inhaltsreich waren zunächst einmal.
Auf unseren Beitrag Bundesregierung wird auf Facebook da haben wir ja darauf hingewiesen dass da viel Geld ausgegeben wird wann dann aber nicht der Lage das mit Ration zustellen Roger.
Hat kommentiert und stellt auch das alles noch mal ein wenig in Relation ich zitiere die Bundesministerien,
Wärme auf Facebook für unterschiedliche Initiativen und Themen beispielsweise für Wissenschaft und Bildungsinitiativen.
Oder auch zu Gründungsteam und Umweltschutz ich finde an der Stelle sollte man auch differenzieren zwischen Ziel und Nutzen der Werbung Inhalt und der unerlaubten Abschürfung Nutzung von Daten im Fall von Cambridge analytica.
Ja sollte man ja also da Mamma e auf dünnen Eis was du die Diversifizierung betrifft und ich finde auch grundsätzlich das.
Würde Werbemaßnahmen auch okay geben also jetzt für konkrete Initiativen die es nicht.
Muss die Bundesregierung den Verben die haben doch ihre chemtrails.
Was sind eben einfach alle ein und dann denken alle schon los also ja wenn das so wäre dann wäre ja eigentlich alles gut was was diskutieren miteinander.
Ich bin mir also ich sehe das also ja.
Gute Romane.
Werbung grundsätzlich Scheiße hat vielleicht schon mitbekommen.
Find Werbung grundsätzlich anstrengend auf weiter sagte auf gute verfügbaren Daten können Zielgruppen bei Facebook gut eingegrenzt werden um den Werbung aussperren.
Das ging ja aber den Plakatwänden wiederum nicht.
Auch nur so begrenzt bin ich sagen weil ja also klar bis man ja kann man den digitalen und insbesondere Facebook anhand der vielmehr Parameter machen.
Das ist Plakatwände komplett Zielgruppen Freiwerden Soße anura nicht also wo die Dinger hängen in welche.
Völlig klar was du völlig klar warst du in Duisburg-Marxloh tapeziert und was du in Berlin Grunewald oder Prenzlauer Berg tapeziert und die NPD kriegt sie auch immerhin ihre komischen Plakate genau da aufzuhängen wo sie jemand.
Das ist aber.
Ja also kann man glauben dass diese Streuverluste ceterasu so viel niedriger sind dass sich das entsprechend lohnt und.
Ich denke auch dass die Rezeption verschiedene Werbemittel unterschiedliches weil es ist ja auch egal hier geht's ja auch hier oben dieses nicht sie werden auf Facebook sollen sie werden an sich die Frage ist halt wofür ne das konkrete Maßnahmen die ausgesetzt wurden für diese Beteiligung suchen meinetwegen,
umso mehr darüber also in diesem Bereich Propaganda guck mal wie toll wir dorthin gehen da wird dann halt schwierig ja.
Längerer kommentar von Roger ich will dir jetzt nicht komplett vorlesen.
Interessant ist er sagte der facebook wer quasi der tausenderkontaktpreis per Facebook versenden Stick und mit dem Gießkannenprinzip bei analoger oder älter Werbeformate wäre wahrscheinlich wesentlich mehr Steuergelder verschwendet worden.
Das finde ich noch ein wichtiges Argument so dann kommentiert Plaste zum digitalen Gesundheitssystem unser erster sagen du hattest ja die Forschergeist Folge erwähnt die heißt jetzt auf release.
Dies ist auch geleast und ich finde davon ganz toll.
Welche Nummer ist das aber die verlinkten immer noch nicht verlinkt was soll das denn.
Eine alten Sendung hat das noch nicht nachgetragen.
Hast du das kann sein.
Topshop nachgetragen Stock mich.
Okay.
Ja also ist die aktuelle Forschergeist Folge 56 die digitale.
Wie sieht ein Gespräch mit Sebastian Kuhn und das ist wirklich geht durch alle Aspekte durch so oder so rum Plaste hat kommentiert.
Und verweist du Lisa mal auf diese Telematikinfrastruktur die so ein Gesundheitssystem zum Einsatz kommt und.
Weist auch darauf hin dass du auf weltweiter Ebene er.
Etablierte Standards anzutreffen sind da ich weiß es nicht ganz genau was dahinter steht HL7 wie kommt man vielleicht wenn man mal beim Arzt Röntgen war ohne CD mitnimmt dann kriegt man alles in diesem schönen die kommen,
Dateien ihe wird er noch genannt weil ich nicht Apple healthkit über das glaube ich auch kurz gesprochen hatten bedient sich wohl auch dieser Standard.
Also konkret wird hier HL7 CDA genannt was auch immer das sein mag ich mir noch nicht so genau angeschaut also wäre zurzeit hier durchaus weltweit etablierte oder Smith.
Externer Standard gibt inwiefern die etablierten technisch beurteilen.
Treffe man bei niedergelassenen Ärzten häufig auf die von den Kassenärztlichen Vereinigung definierten Standard zum Austausch von.
Daten zu also das ist vielleicht auch nicht sonderlich überraschend dass wir dann in Deutschland zumindest noch mal so eine eigene Standards Welt haben Sie vielleicht sehr viel mehr von den hier verbreiteten System mit Geräten definiert wird und dann.
Entsprechend über die Kassenärztlichen Vereinigung zum Standard erhoben werden.
Dann mal der aber noch dass die IP Security hier etwas out-of-scope wäre das.
Scanne ich.
Ja das war dass du dann den Herstellern überlässt die ja dann auch nicht so viel Interesse daran haben dass ihr viel Dings Arbeit und Geld drauf zu.
Verwenden ja und obwohl hier Medizinische Informatik also medizininformatiker beschäftigt sind als Entwickler.
Und hätten hätten wohl auch ein starkes Verständnis von sicherheit aber das ist mir eine Sicherheit die quasi sich auf Patientensicherheit aus und Datenschutz ist das bezieht.
Ja also das korrekte Daten angezeigt werden keine Patienten vertauscht werden vollständige Anzeige von Daten also ganzen Sachen ist auch alles total richtig der konkrete IT security Teil ist,
Seiler Tasse hier auch noch mangelhaft ja.
Eine Sache vielleicht noch meint dass man im Kontext auch betrachten müsste das Software durch regulatorische Vorgaben insbesondere wenn diese zur Ableitung von Behandlung.
Am Patienten genutzt werden regulatorisch medizinische Geräte gleichgestellt sein kann also quasi wie ein Tuch Computertomograph Herz-Lungen-Maschine was ein entsprechendes Overhead in der Entwicklung,
nach sich zieht.
Durch eine regulatorische Vorgaben die auch nicht ganz falsch verletzendes aus dem Computertomograph ist heutzutage im Wesentlichen Software ja mal abgesehen von den physikalischen Eigenschaften diese hier noch mit ins Spiel kommen.
Ein Computertomograph ist ein Computer mit einem weiteren Sinn sag doch keiner dran sodass der Rest ist auf diesem Computer.
Richtig Fenster nehmen.
Ja und ich erinnere dann nur an diesem Fall mit wannacry na also da sind halt Leute die bauen halt im Prinzip.
Diese diese Scanner ja diese diese starken Magnetfeld Magnetfeld Generatoren und entsprechende Treiber für Ihre Geräte und dann ist am Ende ein Computer und der ist eben und teilweise,
dann nicht mit ganz so viel Expertise gesegnet.
Ja
Ich glaube du hast das jetzt gut zusammengefasst.
Der blasse hat noch 1000.
Vorgelesen hättest willkürlich.
Leider geht hier noch ein paar Bildschirmseiten weiter ich wollte die ganzen Fässer jetzt hier nicht aufmachen sollen drauf verweisen dass er ein sinnvoller Kommentar ist wer vielleicht hier auch noch was beizutragen hat kann sich gerne der kommentarliste in unserem Blog,
anschließend wir mal gerne da mal was dabei vielen Dank.
So dann haben wir letzte Woche schon kurz angesprochen da konnte ich es ja kaum glauben weil Mark Zuckerberg hatte ja schon bei seiner Anhörung im US Kongress,
groß erzählt Katerini die dsgvo GVO die datenschutz-grundverordnung das wäre ja was besonders schön ist die ISS,
sehr positiv und er wolle,
alle diese Einstellung überall verfügbar machen nicht nur in Europa und dachte meine Güte das ist wirklich ein feiner,
feiner Zug in der Zuckerberg da macht und jetzt wird's dsgvo wird und dann stellte sich aber rausnehmen doch hat er sich anders überlegt.
Gewerbeschein Erfurt wieder das andere Programme nicht eingeladen.
Gaggenau.
Weil er halt Zulauf vor dem Senat in zum anhörungs Programm lief.
Bisher war es ja so dass alle Facebook-Nutzer die außer der USA oder Kanada sind unter die Datenschutzregeln von Irland fallen.
Denn Irland ist ja das der Teil für den Rest der Rest der Leute liegt quasi das Rest Welt Facebook und.
Hat juristisch und ja auch noch irgendwie am 18. April oder so gesagt ja jetzt schwitzen wir für alle um.
Auf die dsgvo Regeln und.
Dann stellt sich zwei Tage später raus an e wir ziehen lieber mal anderthalb Millionen Milliarden Nutzer von Irland weg.
Und bring die in eine andere Jurisdiktion diese Daten.
Dass wir den ernsthaft diese dsgvo relevanten gesonderten Zustimmungen.
Ausfüllen lassen und das sind die die wir auch letzte Folge schon besprochen haben also Angabe zu sensiblen Daten,
müssen noch mal spezifisch nachgefragt werden ob das wirklich so gemeint war und ob diese Daten geteilt werden sollen Gesicht sehr sensible Daten glaube oder Beziehungsstatus ne Gesichtserkennung.
Tageslänge Deutschland nicht verfügbar wer das zukünftig anmacht.
Muss man aber noch mal gesondert zu stimmt dann diese Zusammenarbeit mit Partnerfirmen wo Facebook also bei Partnerfirmen auch über Like Buttons und so weiter Daten sammelt und weitergibt,
Minderjährige Regelung für Minderjährige wenn man Facebook ab 13 Uhr nutzen will und.
Einschränkungen Regeln als Erwachsene gelten die die Zukunft Einstellung irgendwie anders gesammelt werden soll das ja eben,
dsgvo dann sie sich aber gesagt nee komm wir ziehen über anderthalb Milliarden Nutzer virtuell um als dass wir uns jetzt diese.
Dieser zu begrüßt einen sehr positiven regulation vollständig unterwerfen wie wir's ursprünglich besprochen haben.
Ja da weiß man doch mit wem man zu tun hat ne also.
Nicht wirklich überraschen von.
Das ist doch wirklich toll dass solche Sprüche geklopft werden wenn wenn gerade groß berichtet wird Zuckerberg im Kongress.
Und 2 Tage später wird das einfach wieder wieder eingestampft da weiß man doch was man von seinen Leuten hat.
The visit.
Aber es gibt gute Nacht werden wir jeden zwischen eine gute Nachricht eine gute die ist noch nicht mal so gut.
Jetzt neu.
Jetzt auch mit gute Nachricht.
Also eine der wenigen Sachen die man uns bisher noch nicht verboten hatte.
Wanja Adblocker.
Varia Adblocker und entgegen der Uhr wirklich ihren Erwartungen bleibt das so.
Man City Adblocker Blocker Blocker schon verboten.
Aber die Adblocker die dürfen wir behalten und zwar.
Hat da die Axel Springer AG vor Gericht verloren.
Zumindest vorerst.
Und eigentlich ist das ja immer eine gute Nachricht für die Axel Springer AG mit irgendetwas scheitert in diesem Fall Hype.
Es hat so ein Gewissen Beigeschmack denn die Axel Springer AG hat hiergegen das Whitelisting genannte Geschäftsmodell von Adblock Plus geklagt.
Personello genau.
Ja genau ja die haben ja dieses dieses Modell die haben diesen Adblock Plus und ja im Prinzip quasi sagen sie er wäre jetzt schon mal diese ganzen Werbeflächen die wir hier blocken,
und dann monetarisieren wir unsere Produkte darüber dass ich Leute wieder auf die Werbeflächen zurückkaufen können.
Einfach die Argumentation ganz interessant ne ist leer gerade auch keine Verdrängung vor weil also man könnte ja auch nicht unterstellen dass sie gegen das Werbemodell wehren.
Ohne Werbung wäre hätte auch Ihr Produkt zur Zeit keine Bedeutung.
Ja
Also man muss schon man muss zumindest dazu sein dass dieses Modell von Eier nicht so also das erinnert halt an soll ich mal klassische.
Süditalienische.
Bargeld basierende Geschäftsmodell sowas wie schöne Werbeanzeige haben sie da wäre doch schade wenn die niemand sieht.
Und genau deswegen hat sich ja hier Springer gewährt und ist jetzt.
Erstmal gescheitert vom BGH.
Und jetzt will sie was ich aber noch vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht und gegebenenfalls auch noch wegen Veränderung des Sourcecode urheberrechtlich gegen Eier vorgeht was sie damit jetzt wieder Vorhaben weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe das so verstanden dass das Teil ihrer Strategie ist da vom Bundesverfassungsgericht habe ich mal gespannt was dabei rauskommt auf ihre auf BGH Ebene relativ hoch,
haben sie jetzt schon ziemlich verloren und machen jetzt so Grundsatz Ding draus shalina echt wichtig zu sein.
Ja die haben ja auch also die Rechtsabteilung von Springer muss er auch mal.
Ja gut ich bin bloß gespannt wie das als ob das überhaupt angenommen wird.
Ja das war beim Bundesverfassungsgericht angenommen wird weil es mein.
Dh ist ja quasi jedes beliebige Gesetzen Tickets ja um Wirtschaft und wirtschaftliche Zusammenhänge etc wenn das sozusagen auf Verfassungsgericht eben das Verfassungsgericht ist ja nicht das nächsthöhere Gericht.
In dem Sinne sein.
Kümmert sich ja um was anderes nämlich um die Verfassung so und nicht und nicht primär um die Gesetze die darauf basieren dass es überprüft halt Gesetze ob sie.
Kompatibel sind mit der Verfassung und die ebenfalls werden die halt widerrufen aber ich wäre jetzt auch nicht so überrascht wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich das anschauen sagt ihr Leute damit.
Was anderes zu tun BGH muss reichen batheyer man so schön sagt.
Die werden schon irgendwie schaffen da irgendwas zu ja mal schauen wie wir warten ab.
In Österreich thomas hatte glaube ich über dieses Thema schon hier gesprochen.
Geklagt.
Niklas hat ja gesagt wird wahrscheinlich auch wieder dagegen klagen.
Das Sicherheitspaket oder ein Teil des Sicherheitspaket es ist jetzt durchgekommen,
Überwachung von Messenger mit Hilfe von Trojanern Speicherung von Kommunikationsdaten für bis zu 12 Monate und es gibt auch keine anonymen,
SIM-Karten mehr von Januar 2019 an müssen sich Kunden bei jedem Kauf einer SIM Karte identifizieren oder andere Name und Anschrift,
zu registrieren sind.
Natürlich klar das größte Problem ist hier der Bundestrojaner schreibt auch Thomas Angie epicenter works in der Stellungnahme.
Der Einsatz dieser staatlichen Spionage-Software konnte schon zweimal verhindert werden nun ist der im Gesetz verankert und stellt eine Mann,
Biber Bedrohung für die IT Sicherheit aller Geräte da Österreich beteiligt sich nun aktiv daran Sicherheitslücken für den Bundestrojaner öffnen offen zu lassen anstatt für die Erschließung zu sorgen.
Und ja ärgerlich es ist tatsächlich.
Es war zu erwarten und therapiecenter wird jetzt.
Dagegen auf der nächsten Ebene vorgehen müssen ihr könnt da spenden.
Für die für dieses Team um Thomas Lohninger de.
Korrespondiert.
Korrespondiert und eigentlich hier zum Team schon fest gehört tja.
Was soll man dazu noch sagen.
Spenden und Sponsoring Möglichkeiten geht's auf Unternehmen Sponsoring Möglichkeiten dort na wenn man sich dann hier die Business Loge bei LMP holt da kann man Gold Sponsor Sponsoring von epicenter works mit dazu kaufen.
Wollen wir klagen hier und Österreich ist so voll auf Österreich-Ungarn Film schon nicht mehr feierlich.
Wir bleiben auch thematisch direkt bei Österreich.
Natürlich denn die datenschutz-grundverordnung müsste ja auch in Österreich gelten.
Genau da hatte eigentlich war es quasi noch so ein bisschen vorsichtige vorsichtiger Blick auf das datenschutz-anpassungsgesetz.
Aber da also im Prinzip die Umsetzung der dsgvo in Österreich ja auch Österreich muss ja die dsgvo.
In einem Gesetz quasi umsetzen und da haben Sie sich entschieden pass auf dann machen wir doch direkt mal hier aus diesem Papier einen schönen Papiertiger ohne Zähne und sagen erstens alle Strafen.
Gelten erstmal nur für Wiederholungstäter.
Und selbst davon machen wir noch mal ein paar Ausnahmen dazu komme ich gleich also der ersten Verstoß Bleibt quasi schonmal straffrei öffentliche Einrichtung bleiben immer straffrei.
Dann gibt es eine Ausnahme für Spione die auch für ausländische Nachrichtendienste geht.
Gilt ja weil wenn man mit anderen nachrichten die zusammenarbeitet da sie sagt ja okay Videoüberwachung und Auswertung müssen wir auf jeden Fall erleichtern das ist ja das neue Ding das brauchen wir.
Dass ich gesagt sie hat durch den Wechsel jetzt ab dem 25.Mai.
Also wenn Sie die Tritte am 15 Mai in Kraft was ist jetzt wenn jemand.
Vorher schon den Datenschutz verlässt wird verletzt wird er dann nach der alten oder nach der neuen Rechtslage bestraft oder nicht bestraft und üblicherweise herrlichen Gesetz gilt dann wenn es gilt ne.
Und jetzt haben sie gesagt ja wir machen einfach je nachdem was für eine Täter günstiger ist das heißt wenn du.
Also wenn es dir eine Erleichterung gibt also.
Ich glaube der also nach dem kleinen Rechtsverständnis was mir irgendwie in US amerikanischen Highschools beigebracht wurde Gehen ex-post-facto gesetzte gar nicht.
Also du wirst zu dem.
Aber sie haben sich also in dem Fall geht wahrscheinlich wenn man das wenn es eine Strafe Erleichterung ist geht wahrscheinlich damals gesagt okay wenn du nach Alter Gesetzgebung härter bestraft ist als nach neuer dann nehme die neue.
Und wenn du nach Alter weniger hart bestraft wie es mir mal die alte also zweimal so ne der benevolente.
Richter oder die benevolente Richter sind wie man sie ganz gerne sich auf versteht wenn man mal so als reuiger Sünder vor vor Gericht steht.
Das sind alles extrem anfechtbar.
Wir gucken schlimm wird hier Organisationen die im Auftrag Betroffener Bürger Datenschutzverletzung zur Anzeige bringen.
Dürfen von den Tätern keinen Schadensersatz verklagen.
Und das ist genau das was Max Schrems mit seiner neuen NGO ja quasi vorgesehen hat die immer noch hier bis es 9 Uhr.
Und das ist das ist dein Empfinden also das ist quasi ein empfindlicher Angriff auf die Idee der Verbandsklage.
Oder der wie das glaube ich ihn ja.
Ja Sammelklage.
Verbandsklage ne und es wäre jetzt die Hoffnung eigentlich gewesen.
Das ist eine Möglichkeit gibt für Organisation.
Gegen internationale Konzerne vor Gericht zu gehen um so den Datenschutz durchzusetzen jetzt wenn man das nicht erlaubt müssten Einzelperson das gesamte Risiko tragen.
Und diese Einzelpersonen stehen dann wiederum gegen diesen Heerscharen von Anwälten gegenüber die solche Unternehmen eben unterhalten,
das heißt es ist nicht nur für die Organisation schlecht sondern eben auch für die Rechtsprechung als solche wenn man hier den Menschen die in dem betroffenen die Möglichkeit nimmt.
Sich für ein ausgewogenes Kräfteverhältnis zu sorgen.
Und ich kann aus eigener Erfahrung sagen dieses ausgewogene Kräfteverhältnis.
Ist nicht ist es nicht nur so ist primär natürlich finanzieller Natur als auch von den von dem Aufwand und wie man sich da wie man sich damit beschäftigt her schon allein eine Rolle also wenn du dann mal mit jemanden.
Aneinander gerät der eine Rechtsabteilung hat Dennis diese Rechtsabteilung ganzen Tag mit nichts anderem beschäftigt als dich zu nerven.
Und das machen die gut das machen die sehr gut und da stehst du ruckzuck auf einmal irgendwie sag mir mal das ist keine Seltenheit dass du da in in so ein Prozess.
Eine Prinzessin Sinne von über die Zeit nicht fortschreitender Zustand 5.
Dass du da halt 1er Rechtsstreitigkeiten hast weil jeder einzelne Fall einzeln entschieden wird in der keine Bündel Entscheidung sind und dann stehst du vor der Wahl ob du jetzt als Privatperson sagst alles klar,
Gerichtstermine allein in erster Instanz kriegt dieses Jahr noch unter oder nicht.
Und das ist also eben auch eine sehr sehr starke.
Einschränkung für das Meer für das Menschen sie überhaupt irgendwie mit diesem Datenschutz etwas anfangen können,
Medien gibt's eine Ausnahme dürfen personenbezogene Daten für journalistische Zwecke verarbeiten damit die Kapitel 2 3 4 5 6 7 und 9 dsgvo ignorieren jetzt ist sie also das ist ja so allein so komplexe in der.
Der Abfolge in LED Folgenabschätzung ist ja so komplexes dass sie kaum einer leisten kann.
Dann gibt es ein Privileg für die Bearbeitung personenbezogener Daten für wissenschaftliche künstlerische und literarische Zwecke da gelten auch wieder Teile der dsgvo nicht.
Und der wird angesagt soweit es erforderlich ist.
Um das Recht auf Schutz der personenbezogenen Daten mit der Freiheit der Meinungsäußerung und der Informationsfreiheit in Einklang zu bringen.
Ist da die Formulierung das ist natürlich sehr sehr schwierig es ist eine sehr,
rechts unsichere Formulierung das heißt der wird dann tausend Verfahren wiedergeben weil es da einen unscharfe Formulierung gibt es ihm gesagt haben,
das Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung gegenüber dem Schutz der personenbezogenen Daten steht da da mare,
Ordnung zu schaffen was darf man was darf man nicht haben Sie hier eine sehr eine Formulierung Design.
Wieder irgendwelche klagen durch X Instanzen bringt ne.
Und dann ging Behörden und öffentliche Stellen wie insbesondere in Formen des öffentlichen,
rechts sowie des Privatrechts eingerichtete stellen die im gesetzlichen Auftrag handeln und gegen körperschaften des öffentlichen Rechts können keine Geldbußen verhängt werden.
Das heißt es gibt im Leben einfach eine Generalamnestie für Behörden öffentliche Stellen Körperschaft des öffentlichen Rechts und privat.
Private stellen die für Behördenhandeln quasi eine Generalamnestie können keine Geldstrafen.
Das wurde alles mal eben mal schnell kurzfristig zack-zack.
Von der Nationalratsabgeordneten von ÖVP und FPÖ schnell beschlossen und es ist interessant weil indem in der Stellungnahme vom fasi.
Ähnlich dem gleichen Tag da geht epicenter noch davon aus dass hier noch keine Entscheidung gibt es ist.
Da werden sie halt auch gerade überrannt.
Also klingt für mich natürlich als ob das hochgradig sowohl vom österreichischen Verfassung.
Hops genommen werden könnte weil hier Gleichbehandlung.
Als Info also von euch ja ich meine man kann doch jetzt bitte eine Grundverordnung der Sinn einer Grundverordnung ist.
Einheitliches Recht in Europa durchzusetzen so so ist das da kann man jetzt nicht eingesetzt sagen sagen da ja super Verordnung habt ihr da so die Hälfte davon passt und nicht und wir beschließen jetzt einfach mal dass das nicht gilt.
Das geht nicht.
So und.
Stell dir vor es ist datenschutzgrundverordnung und kein Paket.
Keiner nimmt Ernst ja genau so sagen wir haben Mord ist verboten aber wir bestrafen ist jetzt mal nicht weil Bodennebel.
Doch du bist eine schon nur wir machen bei einem Partner eigene Ausnahme.
Was ist eine GmbH der Dantons Tod geht schon achja Österreich.
Viel zu tun.
Und die schlimmsten.
Viel zu viel zu tun für Epi Center und neu die beiden endlich aus der österreichischen Netzpolitik Stars und Thomas Lohninger.
Ja auf europäischer Ebene wird auch brenzlig für einige.
Britische Unternehmen die nämlich.
EU Domains Domain Domänen in Beschlag haben. EU Domain kann ich beantragen wenn man in der EU ist.
Und jetzt hat die EU angekündigt das wenn man nicht mehr in der EU ist dass man dann die nicht noch nicht beantragen kann sondern dass man sie auch nicht verlängern kann.
Das heißt.
Britische Unternehmen die jetzt Susan Ihr Business über. EU Domains abwickeln sehen sich in einem Zeitraum von ein paar Jahren jetzt geht das ja noch so bis Ende 20:19 Uhr und dann muss ja auch erstmal was auslaufen und so weiter aber so,
diebisch denke ich mal dürfte die EU Domain da nicht so wohl gelitten sein,
keine Ahnung was sie dann machen ob sie dann irgendwie auch für sie okay wieder zurück marschieren ist wahrscheinlich noch in der Hinterhand haben also da wird jetzt niemand bei,
untergehen aber ist dass ich ganz interessant einerseits Wahrheit ist immer wieder bemerkenswert finde wie stark die EU auf.
EU-Ebene.
Auftritt also ich finde ganz ehrlich meine man kann ja Europa viel vorwerfen und das alles nicht perfekt ist und überhaupt und Doof Grad sind die Diskussion habe auch schon 1000 mal das ist ja auch so.
No uns geht langsam und was nicht alles aber ich finde mich wie die EU sich im Falle von brexit auf die Hinterbeine stellt und quasi im Interesse der Gemeinschaft sprich viel schon bemerkenswert.
Sie lassen halt überhaupt nichts aus.
Na ich bin gespannt.
Das wird noch so hart werden für die Briten ich möchte werden.
Relativ bald feststellen also festgestellt haben sicherlich einige schon nur im öffentlichen Diskurs ist halt immer noch nicht angekommen ich weiß nicht genau woran liegt so aber da ganzer,
Spagat der derzeit gemacht wird mit naja wir werden eine Regelung für Nordirland finden.
Ja aber andererseits wollen wir halt auch um die aus der Zollunion dass in single market raus ich glaube dass wenn sie sich durchziehen können am Ende werden Sie feststellen dass der Deal Die Siedler bekommen,
dermaßen Himmel weit entfernt ist von dem was irgendwann mal versprochen wurde bin ich ganz sicher bin wieder die Reaktion die öffentliche drauf sein wird.
Also 20:18 Uhr wird in der Hinsicht noch.
Heinen Löwenstein schneiden kanal damit sie auch damit sie nicht mehr in der EU dran sind Differenzen vereinfachen die werden nicht ich fürchte sie werden nicht.
Auf einmal sagen so scheiße.
Gerne was haben wir jetzt gemacht wir wir wollen doch wieder in die EU war doch eine blöde Idee die ich meine die haben jetzt halt irgendwie die werden halt einfach nur mehr,
Zwietracht und Hass gegen die EU schüren und sagen schaut her jetzt will sie uns unsere schönen Domains Weg als Strafe.
WWE weil sie unsere Milliarden nicht mehr bekommen.
Ja sicherlich mal wieder in der Öffentlichkeit permissiv gespielt wird das haben wir jetzt hier nicht in der Hand so und wievielter bewegt werden kann ist klar andererseits sollte man eigentlich auch drüber freuen wenn es zumindest noch eine Chance gibt,
diesen Euro trumpsta das Heft aus der Hand noch zunehmen.
Also wenn ich sag mal wenn es an die Domains geht da wird der gemeinen Örtchen bisschen.
Und wenn ich wenn bei mir auf einmal aufgrund weltpolitische geschehen oder Referenten oder dummer Fehler auf einmal meine Domains auf dem Spiel Stunden kann mir vorstellen dass.
Überlegst du das auch noch mal mit der Legitimation eines Angriffskrieges.
Bin jetzt die Queen auf einmal auf ihre quinet hör Majesty. EU verzichten muss.
Und die irgendwo irgendwann Spacko wechseln iPad und dann irgendwie da.
Regnet es auf jeden Fall wird noch hart.
Andy werden Sicherheit eine Top Level hintok brexit dann.
Wie finde ich meine Fenster politisch extrem erstrebenswert und ich kann diese nacht nicht ein Scheiß habe ich wäre jetzt auch nicht so überrascht wenn wir im Laufe dieses Jahres.
Auf einmal so ein Moment haben der durch irgendwas ausgelöst wird was noch unklar ist heiß,
fortschreitende Erkenntnisse aus dieser ganzen Cambridge analytica Geschichte Diät schon eigentlich kräftig Bälle macht in Großbritannien dass die Leute da halt einfach mal merken,
wie viel unternehmen quasi dicht machen können wenn.
Nicht mehr weitergeht steigende Preise etc also es kann irgendwas kulminieren und kann irgendwas ganz kleines kann eine ausschlaggebende und dann wäre es eigentlich schon gut wenn wir,
bitte nussmus beiseite lassen können und und und und Großbritannien wieder eingefangen bekommen weil ehrlich gesagt die ich finde die Situation.
Die sich jetzt abzeichnet dass dieses Land nicht in der EU ist können uns derzeit nicht so richtig vorstellen alles wird nicht.
Das wird nicht schön und zwar nicht nur für die nicht schön das wird auch für uns nicht schön.
Ist einfach so ein starker Player mitten in Europa der irgendwie out-of-bounds ist und in seiner seiner Niedergangs Panik und seinem Empire Waren nach allen,
nach allem greift was was irgendwie ihre Situation bessern kann das Bild nicht lustig.
So und was sind internationale diplomatische Krisen und irandil und so weiter angeht und Syrien Situation wird es auch nicht einfacher dadurch also.
Von Mama als Kind ist erstmal die Domain Startups Awards.
Ja in Bielefeld wurden wieder die Big Brother Awards vergeben vom Verein digital courage.
Darm ein paar ausgewählt alle müssen als hier nicht verlesen aber Windows 10 hat ein Big Brother Award bekommen und zwar der Laudator war Frank Rosengart von CCC und der sich die,
vielen verschiedenen Einstellung in Windows 10 angeschaut hat,
wo überall Daten wohin übertragen werden sie es irgendwie an Katana und was nicht alles,
und er sagt er bemängelt vor allem das ist hier nicht die Option übermittle gar nichts gibt,
wo man einfach mal sagt einfache vollständig garnichts übermitteln ich will diesen Computer hier im Haus zu benutzen.
Die sie standardmäßig noch nicht einmal anbieten mir ich erwähne das deshalb weil ich mich da längerer Zeit schon mit thorsten Schröder drunter halten habe der ja auch schon zu Gast war mit dem PC Wahl zusammen aufgebaut hatten.
Der hat da vorbei das ist bestimmt schon ein zwei Jahre her begonnen mal einen privacytools zu machen was im Prinzip alle.
Die erst zwei Jahre auf anderthalb Jahre der die das alle registry entries in den Windows 10 so setzt dass das Ding nicht mehr nach Hause. Also wirklich Fotos an machst und dann kriegst du einmal alles weg.
Und dann fix der die und dann.
Tut das Ding nix mehr und da hat Gibson Tool für hat der Open Source gemacht gibt's auf dem Blog Post für verlinken wir hier und dann erinnere ich mich eben an die vielen Probleme die er damit hatte.
Wir dann immer gesessen hat und geguckt hat das Ding. Immer noch wie kriege ich das jetzt weg wie kriegt das jetzt weg das Tool ist bei uns in den Shownotes verlinkt,
und es ist nicht ohne Probleme weil natürlich wenn diese Dinger soviel nach Hause schicken nach Hause funken,
natürlich auch immer mehr Funktionalitäten dran gebunden werden sodass die Reben bestimmte Funktionalitäten nicht mehr zu Verfügung stehen wenn du nach hause Funke ausschaltest und so also zurecht hier,
ein Big Brother what dann gibt es ein Big Brother Award für den Hessen Trojaner haben wir auch ausführlich hier drüber schon berichtet.
Media hessische Darmstädter cccc sich hier auch gegen gewendet haben mit einer Kampagne und außer und Stellungnahme an den,
Feder für einen Ausschuss und so weiter hier in Hessen dürfen nicht vergessen habe mit CDU und Grüne.
Jameda entschieden haben das nicht nur die Polizei sei auch der Verfassungsschutz schönen den Trojaner einsetzen darf um sogar Gefährder.
Mithilfe der Quellen-TKÜ und der heimlichen Online-Durchsuchung zu überwachen da gab es eine Laudatio von Rolf Gössner der 70er Jahren vom Verfassungsschutz.
Beobachtet wird,
dann gibt es eine auch sehr spannend das war mir gar nicht bekannt da müssen wir auch noch ein bisschen reinschauen von Thilo Weichert unabhängiges Landesdatenschutz.
Dingen landestankstelle Schleswig-Holstein da ist er bekannt hatte eine Laudatio für 10 ISO gehalten.
Bin ne.
Es gibt eine Quartiersmanagement Software wenn du jetzt hier wie diese ganz so Flüchtlinge und Asylbewerber dann irgendwie in,
eine Unterkunft hast ja dann kannst du den jedem einfach so eine Chipkarte geben und dann guckst du halt,
haben die sich hier essen geholt haben die an Aktivitäten teilgenommen und so weiter in der müssen immer einmal ihre Chipkarte reinschieben oder wird es quasi,
alles gebucht wer was gemacht hat das heißt du hast eine relativ ausführliche verhaltensüberwachung auch ne also hat gegessen hat nicht gegessen hatte heute morgen eine Morgengymnastik sich beteiligt oder nicht oder war da oder war nichts,
und dann sagen sie als unbegründet wird das damit dass er bei Ausbruch eines Feuers wissen müssen wir sich aktuell in der Unterkunft aufhältst mit der Begründung könnte man hat also wenn das als Begründung erhält dann können wir natürlich,
demnächst irgendwie im Kindergarten und lassen wir das jetzt einfach nur eine schlechte Idee.
In Andy an die falsche an die falsche Adresse und dann hat Alexa noch einen bekommen,
dass das dieses Assistenzsystem von Abwehr von Amazon,
zudem Laudator nun von digital courage sagte eine abhör spezielle die sich z.b. als Weckerton aber ein allwissender Butler in fremden Diensten ist der sich von mir höchstpersönlich ins Schlafzimmer tragen,
und an das weltweit weltweite überwachungs netzanschluss Test.
Es gab es nicht das erste Mal dass so ein Sprachsystem von digital courage einen Big Brother Award erhält.
2015 habe ich da mal einen vergeben und zwar an diese hello Barbie wo wir auch schon an solchen Sprachassistenten wo wir dass ich das auch angesprochen hatte wo es eben auch darum geht.
Das hier.
Die Leute die diese Dinger kaufen da stehen eben nicht dass diese Dinger die ganze Zeit ihre Mikrofone an haben damit sie Alexa hören und nichts,
auf magische Weise erst das Mikrofon einschalten wenn sie Alexa hören weil sie sind nicht sonst keinen Sinn so hätten um Alexa,
zuhören ich hatte die hello Barbie damals dafür ausgezeichnet weil sie eben in den Kindi Kinderzimmer geht und da schon quasi an früher Stelle.
Ein unkritischen zu einem unkritisch Umgang mit derartigen Objekten erzieht und weil das Ding außerdem noch irgendwie sowas hatte wie.
Hier die Eltern können gucken was die Kinder der Puppe erzählt habe die ganzen Aufzeichnung wo der gespeichert.
Dann kommen wir tatsächlich wenn Du es zulässt Tim zu Kurzmeldung.
Ich es zulasse.
Die Sache ist wenn du dass wir könnten jetzt hier Kurzmeldung machen.
Ja aber.
Kurzmeldung Nummer 1 wir gucken einfach mal wie weit bekommen Kurzmeldung Nummer 1 seit vielen Jahren zieht sich inzwischen dieser Rechtsstreit hin zwischen.
Guitar people for the ethical treatment of animals und dem Fotografen Wie heißt da je David.
David Slater.
David Slater war irgendwie bei so dem wie Fotos von Makaken gemacht und dann hat ein Affe.
Der in 1 Million Artikeln die ganze Zeit als Naruto bezeichnet wird der ist ein eigentlicher Name aber Ella ist sind die Kamera genommen und einige Fotos gemacht darunter ich glaube insgesamt drei oder vier selfies von sich selber.
Vielleicht auch nur zwei.
Grandiose Bilder.
San Jose Bilder die besten selfies die je von einem Makaken angefertigt wurden so und Lisa.
Dieser Fotograf hat dann wie selbstverständlich sein,
Urheberrecht an diesen Bildern geltend gemacht und dann gabs erstmal Rechtschreib darein mit Wikipedia weil Wikipedia dieses dann sagst du ja so Entschuldigung du kannst also das Bild hast du nicht gemacht und deswegen hast du nach langlochziegel,
Rechtsprechung auch kein Urheberrecht an diesem Bild und Peter haben natürlich der gesagt nein der Affe hat eine Uhr im Recht und wir sind natürlich die wirklichen Vertreter seines Wunsches was damit passiert.
Wuschel alles in B relativ hässlich der Fotograf verkauft diese Bilder ohnehin irgendwie signiert von sich selber oder was oder,
und gib dann irgendwie so und so viel Prozent des Geldes an diesem akhaten Reserve,
wurde ich Hafen wurden also das ganze Ding ist völlig absurd leider gewonnen auch wirklich nicht mehr witzig weder für den Fotografen noch für Wikipedia noch für Peter der Fotograf hat zwischendurch halt irgendwie einnehmen,
am Rande des Ruins wie das eben so ist wenn eine organisierte Organisation,
Rechtsabteilung und finanziellen Mitteln dich als Privatperson einfach von einem Gericht für das nächste schleppt,
und du jedesmal ging auf die all diesen Mist lesen und antworten muss das würde sehr unschön.
Vor allem ich meine was hat er schon groß gemacht.
Gemacht.
Wer hat Fotos veröffentlicht so ich meine Hand nicht irgendjemanden.
Ja er hat auch er hat auch natürlich versucht seine Urheberrecht eine Bild Kelten zu machen dass er aber wie das eben so ist eine andere Rechtsstreit ne.
Das Ding ist eine lange Tragödie aber jetzt an der US Court of Appeals for the ninth circle.
Hat am Montag die Klage von Peter abgewiesen die nämlich die Vermarkter und damit hat der,
David Slater jetzt die Vermarktungsrechte an den Bildern war eben diese Klage abgewiesen wurde er hat jetzt also das Recht die Bilder zu verkaufen sondern auch Urheberrechtsverletzung einzuklagen.
Mit anderen Worten wenn ihr irgendwo noch so ein Bild verpasst auf weil ich jetzt jetzt hat er Slater den Dreh raus mit den Geschichten.
Okay das Ding hat also jetzt ein ein ein trauriges Ende und am Ende hat niemand gewonnen Kathrin Meyer von.
Wikipedia hatte auch so eine längere wietreie zugeschrieben weil das der offenen Wikipedia natürlich ein Problem war na ja.
Und merkt euch das Tier heißt Ella und nicht Naruto könnte alle abmalen viele als Lügenpresse Lügenpresse gemacht haben.
Ich habe ihnen besser erinnerung war bei der Freak Show ja auch beim.
Hatte ich lange Zeit als Twitter Avatar.
Die Folge ist mach den Affen Weg und.
Ronny hat nicht mehr auf mich oder aufgehört.
5 Minuten lang nicht mehr aus dem lachfestival können alle nicht mehr als.
Hockey kann damit an.
Gut gewartet hat das gut gemacht.
I Kurzmeldung.
Erzählen.
Zoll Bundesverwaltungsgericht Köln hat sich der Meinung des nordrhein-westfälischen Oberverwaltungsgerichts angeschlossen.
Eine Entscheidung im vergangenen Sommer und stellt fest dass das deutsche.
Die deutsche Vorratsdatenspeicherung also das zuletzt ausgelobte Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgesetzt wie viele Variante von Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist das ist eine hin Deutschland Wesen 3.
EDV Datenspeicherung nach Maß.
Jorma wird eine Zahl verstößt gegen Europarecht.
Ja das war ja auch klar das haben wir auch damals immer gesagt und deswegen musste der Master jetzt am Ende auch weg befördert werden sind Außenministerium.
Nicht dass er das jetzt noch ausbaden muss.
Ja also das wurde einfach nur bestätigt schön danke dass das Ohr Verwaltungsgericht Köln hier auch dass Opa recht Europarecht studiert hat.
Ja das bedeutet faktisches für immer noch keine funktionierende Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland haben müssten eigentlich wenn sich alle richtig verhalten.
Und dann komm jetzt heim fröhliche Lied.
Beim fröhlichen Lied Convair.
Rainer Wendt.
Louis kein echter Polizist Rainer Wendt immer noch.
Vorsitzender der DPolG e wenn ich mich nicht täusche ich habe nicht mitbekommen dass der zurückgetreten ist.
Ich auch nicht wer war ganz angemessen gewesen.
Wäre angemessen gewesen denn er hat über 11 Jahre.
Volle Bezüge als Polizist bezogen.
Als obwohl er hauptberuflich tätig war als Bundesvorsitzender der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft.
Und im deutschen Beamtenbund der Typ hat 11 Jahre lang nicht als Polizist gearbeitet.
Hat dabei volle Bezüge bekommen und noch eine Beförderung kassiert zusätzlich bei Beamten geht das nach Dienstjahren und so ne das ist also quasi vorgezeichnet das ist jetzt das Ergebnis.
Wo zwei Regisseure nachgestellt freigestellt wurden die,
die Personalakte Vermerke in der Personalakte 40 Personen befragt haben Dienstvorgesetzte aus diversen Polizeibehörden und den Zeitraum von 1990 bis 2017 auf gearbeitet haben ja,
der Typ war ohne rechtliche Basis 11 Jahre nicht im Dienst,
volle Bezüge kassiert Beförderung kassiert es gibt irgendwie eigentlich nichts schöneres als als den Typen dann ernst sich die noch nicht einmal.
Auf dieser DVD da endlich raus zu kicken und natürlich wird er ein.
Riesenproblem für das Innenministerium für die für die ganze Geschichte da in Nordrhein-Westfalen sein weil man sich natürlich auch fragt wie kommt das zustande.
Und das ist wirklich nicht in Ordnung und genau die und diese interne Untersuchung kommt eben auch zu dem Schluss dass diese Besoldung unrechtmäßig war das ist nicht nur das ist sogar.
Unrechtmäßig das ist nicht nur geschmacklos sondern sogar auch unrechtmäßig.
Sogar das.
Ja was ja erstaunlich ist.
Hat man ja selten normalerweise sind Geschmacklosigkeiten ja rechts mäßig ja ist ja so.
Rad.
Und damit wären wir bei den Terminen.
Und zwar LocoNet für TV 46 noch mal ankündigen wireless bei euch auch nicht Hammer nämlich schon angekündigt vielen Dank dass ihr uns mehrmals daraufhin falls.
Ja Sport zurück.
So ist das in den verteilten letzten.
Zum 19. Mal findet am 28.09 April in München das so Vintage Computer Festival Europe Start Ziel des Vintage Computer Festival ist.
Den Erhalt und die Pflege historischer Computer und anderer elektronischer und anderer,
datenverarbeitungsgesellschaft zu fördern das Interesse an überflüssiger Hard und Software zu wecken und vor allem den Spaß daran auszuleben ich find ja diese Vintage Computing Festival immer echt ganz cool also wenn das in Berlin ist gehe ich da gerne hin.
Alleine mir echt diese diese Maschine anzuschauen und ihr wie auch so in Vergangenheit zu schwelgen und so deswegen ist das hier das vcfe.
Herzlich ins Herz gelegt 28 und 29 April in München Link in den Schoß.
War auch mal eine Weile her muss man sagen das gibt's auch schon seit Ewigkeiten das gesagt ne 19. mal ja ja.
Altersheim vcfe weiß noch nicht.
Das ist doch das mit jeder neuer ja das nicht ob es noch dieselbe Location ist geht das ja.
Muss ich noch mal muss mal kurz schauen wo das Wetter stattfindet.
Vorhin Fall interessant was alles zu einer alten scheiße angekarrt wird ne sicher fragen.
Soll ich mir alte Computer angucken und dann kann man glaube ich nur entgegnen.
War das ist so geil.
Hilft enorm beim Verständnis von Computern Ansicht sich auch die alten Sachen anzuschauen also ich habe.
Also vor allem so Sachen die man noch nie gesehen hat meinst du die Nostalgiker dieses Mal wieder meinen alten zuversichtlich streicheln oder was auch immer.
Das mache ich regelmäßig.
Ja andererseits finde ich finde ich immer spannend besonders so die die die Dekade davor also bevor ich selber eingestiegen bin vielleicht auch noch davor.
Da immer wieder so wunderbare aha Momente weil sich Begriffe erklären lassen in Zittau und.
Wir wollen senden vielleicht auf dieses Jahres ja auch noch mal so ein bisschen Vintage anschauen im Ausland.
Oh ja ja.
H&M und Chor.
Irgendwo steht immer im Chorraum das nicht immer am geilsten weil es ist ja auch schon begriffen also jeder der mit Unix gearbeitet hat und im Programm beim abstützen gesehen hat sowieso ein Chor Darmstadt finden.
Ist eigentlich wird es in Lateinisch von Kern oder 4 Kern an ich zum kleiner Magnetring ist so super drehte durchgebissen wo man noch ganz genau verstehen kann dieser Computer mal was gespeichert hat ist schon geil.
Ja das ist das ist wirklich ans Herz gelegt und das ist aber ich auch jetzt schon bald ne 28.09 dieses Wochenende.
Steinmännchen nee leider nicht.
So and also fast.
Passt ich danke Thomas.
Simon Niklas Sören Christian und Benjamin für Sonne Großzügigkeit.
Wir bedanken uns bei allen sonstigen Bändern der Metaebene und natürlich auch bei allen künftigen Ticket Koffern von Logbuch Netzpolitik 256.
Und die schaffen viel schon.
Die T-Shirts sind verschickt und was das Besondere an diesen T-Shirts ist muss man ja auch mal sagen es ist seit vielen Jahren das erste Mal dass ich einen Druckauftrag efin T-Shirts die nicht scharf sind.
Und vielfarbig die Herz auch schon ne.
Wie fahre ich schon aber es ist tatsächlich Camp 2015 habe ich das letzte Mal nicht schwarze Rohwaren Druckauftrag.
Also doch nicht das erste Mal.
Seit vielen Jahren.
Gut so kurze Sendung aber gesagt.
Hammer gesagt haben wir gemacht.
Ja so in etwa das war's Leute bis bald.
Bis bald ciao ciao.